Jurgen Kazakh in Saxony Sophie Cocke
want citizens to be more engaged in
Germany and Christian Hartman warns
against a total condemnation of the
inhabitants of Saxony I met with these
three and others to discuss how they're
dealing with far-right extremism Jurgen
Kazakh actively campaigns against it
he's organized numerous actions to
promote tolerance despite neo-nazis
trying to intimidate him into silence
horn come has Mia's become anonymous
threats hate mail anonymous calls at
work recently a total stranger costed me
on a tram in light station where I
normally feel safe I'm gay people follow
the funnel person is kenna on this Bible
zoom in certain places and situations i
found i really have to keep my wits
about me it's made me a bit paranoid
look for tata hispano you every week
more than two thousand supporters of the
right-wing group iggy dad take to the
streets why here experts say that Saxony
which was part of the old East Germany
is successful to extremism because
people here lack an understanding of
democracy and political organizations
generally have a lot fewer members in
eastern Germany than in the West I'm
here to meet the biggest youth
organization in Saxony the young
socialists they have 1000 members
lobortis and gardens accent a lot needs
to be done in Saxony about political
education democracy must be fostered in
schools but as long as that's not the
case people here won't find democracy
attractive enough to actively contribute
to it these young politicians say that
for a long time nobody dared to speak
about what was happening in Saxony state
that's been labeled as a right-wing
that's not attractive so everyone's
going to deny that Saxon ease former
premier one said Saxony is immune to
right-wing extremism and only two years
later
the NPD a far-right party won seats in
the state parliament banget solvers it's
certainly not easy to get state
politicians to talk about right-wing
extremism on camera only one of them
agrees to talk to me Christian Hartman
from the Christian Democrats he admits
that in the years after the fall of the
wall his party failed to invest in
political education that made it easy
for right-wing populist to establish
themselves but he wants to fight the
perception that everyone in Saxony is an
extremist so tightest a focal search dog
off we have difficulties with right-wing
extremism we must step up the political
will to address as you become from that
said it's not everyone expressing an
opinion or voicing concerns about
refugee policy is a right-wing extremist
who's put it certainly not every sack
sensor missiles and some garlic eaters
AXA my last stop is at hearts instead of
hate a protest movement against the far
right Rita qunut is one of its founders
they want to get 5,000 people out onto
the streets they debated for a long time
whether they would let us film them to
take a public stance against the
far-right can be dangerous they say they
gave up trusting the police and
authorities a long time ago I English
would ye deport astok any form of
protest even ours is being actively
discouraged by the police and the
authorities it's I if you hadn't heard
lets us last year there were more than
20,000 people on the street but did not
see groups were rampaging through the
city to call the police let them run
wild inside us when they attacked our
rally the police just stood by and did
nothing to stop them buchwald elsewhere
that's not normal but here it is
poisoned of acute the plea this year
they're hoping their demonstration for
freedom equality and humanity will pass
off without incident